Hello everybody!
The beeping on this title screen is so scary.
Phantom maxing, racing, absolutely spooking it!
So stinking true, we're freak maxing, we're ghost maxing,
we're haunts maxing, we're mint maxing!
I don't know why I'm maxing everything today.
The chart, the, there we, the, the, the, the maxing is off
the charts.
We, I don't know how much more I can max out.
How much more?
Freak maxing.
We're not maxed out.
We're probably close though.
We're probably close.
Hello everybody, welcome to ViewFinder.
I was like super in the mood for a, how do you say, like a
super liminal Stanley Parable.
Oh, Casey's, oh my gosh.
Thank you for the Aqua Supa.
Oh, your cat.
Dash and I often watch streams together, so thank you for
being entertainment for us and indirectly helping me through
this drying time.
I'm so sorry.
But 19 is so old.
You must have loved your cat.
I'm sorry.
Yeah, good long life.
Oh my god, I'm immediately crying.
19 in cat years is like dust the thing you the you know when
like old people you could like you can like smell them you
can smell the old like with cats it's quite similar but like
their fur is like something else it's their fur becomes like
so it's not matted it just looks strange is it the smell of
decay i never got there so i wouldn't know but yeah my dog
lived until 21 holy cow i was there did you have a big dog i
feel like small dogs do not live very long but big dogs big
dogs are dumb and resilient you know
small dogs live longer wait really wait am i crazy i thought
i thought that small dogs are always plagued with health
problems it's the opposite maybe i'm only i'm projecting all
the pugs problems onto other small pugs and chihuahuas i'm
i'm projecting them onto onto large dogs large dogs have
joint issues which ruins their fitness See, now, you know,
like, weiner dogs have so many joint issues and spine
issues.
Dogs with short legs.
Yeah, I don't know.
Also, if you don't hear anything from the game, I don't
think there's any music on this title screen, so we're just
deaf together, I guess.
We're so lucky to have a Oshi so...
smart are you being sarcastic dog
wait for some reason my my obs is being so strange phoenix
thank you so much i oh there it is okay it wouldn't let me
scroll to see well thank you for the very spooky don't know
i left my job to hike the appellation trail in february but
i only made it 150 miles only 150 miles before getting a use
injury At least I have my very own filthy minto plush
Starting my new job next month So I passed my spare luck
Onto you, Aibus Beep Beep Well,
wow Only 150 miles before an injury Come on, Phoenix What
the heck What the heck, that's crazy though That's so
awesome That's so awesome And congrats on the job And I
think we have a birthday, Zero Deals!
Happy birthday!
Oh, another birthday!
Danko!
Happy birthday!
Okay, we will sing an MGS birthday song for you both.
Happy birthday, congratulations!
Happy birthday with salutations!
Happy birthday, may your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you Happy birthday I got a day off of work
to finally relax and crack open a cold one I love watching
your stream Can't wait to watch your new outfit reveal
Merlock, thank you I hope you relax nice today then Happy
Friday everybody, happy Friday New outfit reveal I can say
that I got important things received for my alpha reveal so
Monday is for sure a go baby yeah yeah yeah I got it I got
it yesterday actually so I stayed up a little bit later um
finishing up some things um that needed to get done uh but
yeah just a few extra days just a few extra days
does it come with a bald toggle they all come with a bald
toggle they all come with a bald toggle
yes um oh my gosh today it's so sunny a nice out though i
was like what if i what if i what if i what if i skip what
if i i was like what if i skip school what if i what if i
play hooky that's why you're the best boss yeah stream
outside maybe but i i will be gone a couple of days next
week because there is off kai off kai happening and also
take a couple extra days to hang out with some friends that
um are heading to off car so um i will be off a couple days
i'm i'm currently in like cleaning slash recording slash
work prep hell i'm trying not to record so much but i need
to record a little bit because you know the show was coming
up and everything and um i have a karaoke after my after my
debut but uh
yes so um have fun at archive thank you thank you thank you
uh we'll see if i stream because i will have my stuff uh
it's just a matter of if i can tdf my vacation is coming
soon and i'm flying off to San Jose next week.
Have a nice flight, Verla!
TTIF!
Please keep Vicky safe from Murica and show her around.
I don't know anything.
What do you mean?
First of all, that's like kind of weird.
Not weird.
It's like, okay, America is so big.
I'm going to a part of America.
I have only been to once.
What am I going to show her around to?
What am I gonna do?
Oh, here's the sidewalk.
We don't have many of these here.
Um...
Uh...
You said weiner dogs, but mine is 18 years old.
I'm not saying all dogs.
But I don't know.
It's just what I heard.
Show her the McDonald's, which they definitely have in
Japan.
Show her burger.
They definitely have those in Japan.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Show her around.
What am I supposed to show?
I'm also a tourist in this place that I'm going to.
I have no idea.
We were actually looking at, like, maps of places to go to
yesterday.
We were like, where can we eat?
In fact, Phoebe should be the one showing us around.
Phoebe is Californian.
Burger Eagle explosives done and dusted.
That's us.
Oh, you forgot a yee-haw right in there?
Yeah, I don't know anything.
I go and I'm like, Someone help me.
Take me around, please.
Help.
In and out, I actually do want to go to, though.
We had this discussion the other day.
I want to go to in and out.
Costco, though, they have Costco in Japan as well.
And it's about the same menu.
The only difference is instead of the chicken bake, it's a
bugogi bake.
So it's a little different.
Hello, Mindo.
And I was like, ew.
Can't wait to see you at Offka next week.
Really excited.
But also anxious for the trip.
But I know it'll be sick.
It'll be so hecking sick, baby.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Take my southern card away.
I'm unworthy.
Yoink.
Take her to Olive Garden.
I heard.
I heard that they are bringing back the, uh, some sort of
like pasta thing.
I saw, I saw a video about it.
I saw TikTok about it.
It was like, it's like not the, it's a pasta.
It's, it's unlimited pasta.
You pay a certain amount and for a certain time, you get
unlimited pasta.
I don't know if that's, if that's not the most American
thing ever.
I don't know what is.
It's sold out!
What?
Wait, I didn't get one!
I don't even know where in all of Garden is!
Stop coming though!
Legends Anu is looking incredible and I'm really happy
seeing Ten Setsu thriving so quick, so fast.
Hope y'all have fun!
Thank you!
We do have streaming tickets for Legends Anu as well.
It's gonna be a crazy show!
So awesome!
So, uh...
So yeah.
Asayoru Cafe is LA, if I remember correctly.
So that's like a 7-hour drive.
Yeah.
Imagine subscribing to pasta.
Me.
I would subscribe to pasta.
Just a quick local USA trip.
Yeah, same state.
Seven hours drive everybody same same state california yeah
yeah if you don't if you don't know the scale of america it
really just kind of wax you in the face when you're like i
want to go from i want to go to asayoru after afkai okay
enjoy it enjoy the ride unlimited pasta they could solve
world hunger
I had spaghetti last night and I think I'm gonna have it
again.
I had spaghetti last night and I'll do it again.
You can't stop me.
Each state is a small country, except New England.
How big is New England?
Let's walk to Seattle right after Off-Kai.
Oh yes, it's so...
You just have to pass through one state.
It's so easy.
Skedimaxing.
I guess lineup for Skyline Serenade is shaping up to be
super exciting too.
Yes, yes.
We also, yeah, the Skyline Serenade tickets are still on
sale for during Anime NYC weekend.
And yeah, I'm excited.
First, I gotta get through the first show though.
I gotta get through Legends Anu though.
then you can see the statue of liberty after just a short
drive who's all who's up for a small humble road trip after
off kai to the statue of liberty so easy so easy you got
this thank you i'm so nervous i'm so nervous me me me me
we're gonna go on the the diarrhea lettuce extravaganza road
trip tour hit up every taco bill in the mead wish what
snacks are you bringing cheese it
and pirates booty and kettle chip you get those three things
from me I got lettuce from a fast food place today I am very
brave everybody give Mobius fun a medal for your bravery
instead of a purple heart you get the brown heart I'll see
you in two weeks, I guess.
Oh,
seven for your bravery.
Mobius, you're playing with fire.
Yeah, the ring of fire.
That will be your butthole when you get the fire.
Apparently California is safe from the illness.
Is it really?
No way.
Off collab RV there yet with more hand puppets.
Wait, like everybody?
Or...
For now.
Plus, we can never open the car window during the trip.
Wait, wait, wait, why, why, why?
That's so evil.
You don't like putting your hand out the window and doing
like the...
The swimmy motion, like you're a dolphin with your hand?
Do you not do that?
Oh, the smoke!
That's right, the wildfire smoke.
Oh my god.
All right, trip cancelled.
Trip cancelled.
I did that real dolphin hours on the road.
Oh, oh, I hope you guys have good air purifiers and stuff.
Update on the Taco Bell for me.
I didn't get it.
How long ago?
It has an incubation of two weeks.
I can't believe they're putting glass in the bread and poop
juice in the salad.
I'm scared to eat anything in America now.
Me too.
We have a great time and please come...
Oh, wait, not we.
Have a great time and please come home with lots of fun
stories.
You've been working so hard lately.
You deserve it.
Hope to see you there, Minto.
Yeah, I'll see you there.
I'll see you there.
See you, see you.
Mmm.
I'm excited, though.
I don't have, I mean, I was looking at my schedule for
Off-Kai.
I probably won't have much time to do much else besides,
like, what I'm scheduled to do.
But that's okay.
I'm very excited to see everybody.
I hope everybody who's going has a really awesome time.
And if you're not going, I hope that maybe you can have a
watch party with your friends of Legends Anu.
Hmm.
Shall we get started with the game, though?
finder yes I want to play one game one second oh my gosh I
keep getting spam calls I keep getting the most spam calls
ever actually it's just two a day but it's still so annoying
actually one day I got three in the same day and they call
so early they call it like 8 a.m.
it's crazy if you find her the only view i need is the cutie
patootie and the bottom left
i only get one a day lucky you how many years has this been
going on not years maybe it started like earlier this year i
started getting them but i get i get two maybe three a day
let's see i'm scrolling my entire i don't call anybody i
sometimes just get calls from my mom and my entire thing is
is is spam spam mom mom spam spam spam spam spam spam spam
spam spam spam spam spam spam spam spam spam spam spam spam
spam spam so much so much spam it's ridiculous i got i got
sold out hard man stage left surely who Sorry, I'm in bottom
right.
I didn't hold my hand up to make the L.
Wait, you're right.
I am in the right.
Wait.
Send stage left.
Oh.
Who are you talking about?
Over there.
Oh, good, good, good.
Could it be?
No way.
He's been here the whole time.
The cutie in the bottom left.
And he's so talented too.
There's no way I can compete.
I'm gonna start the game, I'll show you, I'll show you my
real talents with my big massive brain.
Let's start the game.
Initializing.
Beep, beep, beep, peep, beep, beep, beep.
Great, we're in.
Hi Jesse.
Time to explore!
Explore?
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
I could sit
This is See, I just want to I just want to sit and Enjoy the
breeze What is, what's on the, what's on the radio
27 months Thank you, Joel the Prime Ranser Thank you Thank
you
I already know how to jump.
Wait, is that food in there?
What's on?
Oh, to think all the wonders of the world can be dabbled
with as long as you build the right space.
Whether Hiraya wants to admit it or not, Miran is truly
brilliant.
Now, how do I get out of here?
Are you stuck in the... Are you stuck in there?
What is this?
There seems to be no kind of...
of crouch.
Okay.
Freaky.
I don't know if- I don't think this game is creepy.
I think it's actually quite- I've never seen this much
overgrowth before.
I think it's quite cute and puzzly.
It's beautiful.
Is this what it used to look like?
The world.
Oh, wow.
But we're in the sky.
Ah!
I am!
Me?
Uh, your vitals look good.
I guess we know now that falling doesn't hurt.
That's some good news at least.
There must be a way to get back up there.
Uhhhh...
Oh, you're what?
That's sick!
Aww.
So...
Will this one fall?
Oh, nice, it didn't.
Okay, what about this one?
Only ever seen one clip of this game but a good one.
One, but a good one.
Yeah, I'm excited to see what kind of interesting puzzles we
get into.
It's hard not to just sit here and take in the view.
Just chirping up there.
The breeze, the sunlight.
It feels real.
one but a good one all right one thing is i do wish i there
was a run toggle there's more going on over here even oh
there's so much everywhere are they just what happened to
them to believe that we've all finally managed to come
together come together team of brilliant minds here to bring
to life my vision or rather our vision our vision to detail
our first list of tasks then thank you so we're not like
because the jesse girl she was like oh your vital signs look
good so we're not jesse we are our own being maybe we're
like a little robot creature or something or other all right
what's going on here this what's an old photograph doing
here and
did you just shift reality no way that was so crazy oh there
I go I'm James oh no did you just shift reality no freaking
way that was so freaking epic where did I come from though
Teleporter needs to be powered!
Is this just how we're putting in batteries now?
That was Awesome Sauce, mega epic teleportation,
giga-thinking maxing.
Oh, there's another one.
Let's see.
Can I take the creepy Aval?
No.
Anyway.
What happened to everybody that they just like They even
left their bean bag chair for me to sit in.
Hiraya has finally agreed to let me paint her.
I've convinced her to visit me in my favorite places and
even offered to brew her tea.
She denied.
At the very least, I'll now have something to show her
whenever she doubts herself.
She's everything I see in her and more.
I'm glad she's here.
I wonder what her favorite flower is.
oh but what's what was what was this little red part at the
top nothing okay
it's so quiet here it is except for these stinking bugs you
know i cannot stand these types of activities here i am my
love please hold still what do i even do with my hands just
relax them and try to smile our portrait digital landscape
tell me is this technically traditional or digital enough
questions stop moving smile what'd you do to her why did you
make her face like that what okay picasso over here let's
take the other photo let's aim it like right there holy
freaking bonkers cows lay epic problem solving that's me i'm
placing the battery hey that's good no way did you just lay
shift lay reality
I don't know why I'm- I'm feeling a little sassy today,
maybe.
Sorry.
I don't know why.
I- I can't stop.
Oh, we're going to the beach!
Oh, that- that- the not.
Okay.
I'm just ruining this entire landscape.
Oh, I'm- oh, sorry.
Sorry.
I realized- Oh, God!
Oh, God!
God, oh, oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh, God.
I gotta get out of here.
Hey, there we go.
Where are we going?
Where, what are we doing?
Virgil's plastic chair.
Scum.
Whoa, this place definitely feels different than what we've
seen so far.
Does it?
Oh, I like that.
Yeah, they have like, they have, it's an actual house.
Yeah.
They love painting here.
Like they are mega painters.
There must be a security measure.
A structured path we have to follow.
Well, let's find the next working one.
Oh, I like the music.
Everybody deserves it.
A chocolate bar!
Rethinking my plans to bring precious delicate items to the
Tencent Dynasty Concert.
No!
There's nothing...
It looks like someone really settled here.
They fed off of only chocolate bars and dates.
It's really nice.
I wish I could be in there with you.
Well, come on in.
The water's just fine.
Look at this table!
I'm sorry!
What?
Late epic turtle table.
I need this, I think.
I'm rethinking my whole decorating process.
How many people were in here though?
Like, there's so much going on.
This must be the next stage.
Let's go!
Where are we going?
What are we doing?
Art.
The turtle is super epic.
Mega epic.
Reminds me of that belief that the whole world is on the
back of a turtle or something.
Oh!
You know what you're talking about.
Yes, yes, they even painted the bag!
These people are so artsy-fartsy.
Super artsy.
I mean, maybe I would be so inspired if I lived here too.
Hmm?
What am I aligning this with?
Oh.
Follow the gray brick road.
Alright, Jesse.
Jesse.
Can you pick up the photo?
It almost is like the frog is dead.
I forgot the frog!
Do you guys want him there?
It's kind of funny.
Maybe there's a surface you can use to climb up there.
Or a ducky.
One out of four collectible ducky.
Yes, keep him.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
I need...
I need to understand.
This place, beautiful as it is, carries so much weight.
There is promise here.
Promise of a future we can surely achieve.
Even now, I'm striving to reach heights I never thought
possible.
All that I hope is that everything we do here continues to
have meaning out there as well.
A logograph.
what are they doing here then and everybody laughed oh like
this oh I I wish they I need the tutorial to stop now like I
understand how to rotate photos and stuff like I don't want
to I don't want to be handheld through the puzzles please
game please I do not wish to be handheld hmm
Turn them off.
Let's see.
Graphics maybe?
Or no.
It would be under general maybe?
Accessibility?
Why did they choose this?
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep,
peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
It doesn't seem like it.
Hmm.
Too bad.
You can look around.
using mouse thank me later oh my god you're right wait I can
now I can finally play the game thank you never thought I'd
be getting jealous of a tutorial wait why a treasure in the
making oh brother what's this one her future skies are Oh,
this one's pretty, though.
Can we really blame the game for wanting to hold hands with
Minto?
Oh, that's what you mean, you goof.
You goofball.
Let's see.
Alright.
Let me actually pay attention, though.
Figure out what we're doing.
Was there a way inside?
I didn't see any Did you guys?
Unless these can be taken.
I don't know.
I don't think so, though.
Well, I wouldn't.
Oh, I can.
I can swap between multiple photos using Q.
Oh, look at that.
I can even...
Wait.
What does this do, though?
The photos on the board.
Yeah, I was looking for black and white photos.
I didn't realize they would come in color, too.
Hmm.
I ate the whole room on accident, though.
Wait.
Hold on.
I have to see what's in here.
I didn't know if that would work or not.
Oh, yeah.
What if I...
Oopsie.
If I...
I can't do it the same way...
the other way either wait i
don't know why this thing is so if i had a quarter of your
talent with a brush or half mirin skill with a lens i would
immortalize your napping habits friend i don't think i've
ever seen someone strike such inventive tableaus while in
repose unfortunately for your latest ducky masterpiece your
naps happen to be prime mischief making hours.
Come to my domain at half past two tomorrow for an hour's
worth of hard labor, mixing soil.
If you ever wish to see Poe Quackles de Guzman again, with
grave respect, Hiraya.
Where's, so the ducky's gone?
The ducky's been held hostage?
It's terrifying.
Maybe this is a horror game.
what an interesting way to place batteries very interesting
yeah it just eats the whole room
how can we make it not eat the room
what if i like place it here what does it do
so cool such a cool effect
It's still there.
It's always good to experiment.
There we go.
Good enough, I guess.
Wow.
Oh, I like the way the sun...
I'm staring at the sun.
But I like the way it looks under the green.
Success!
Oh.
Take a look.
them.
It's alive!
Yeah, too much.
Yeah, cool.
Jesse, yeah.
Jesse's really getting into it.
What do they say?
Mirin prefers cooler tones for her workspace.
Find a better gradient.
I've been working on a series of paintings, one to represent
each of us.
It's a great way to document history.
Hiraya has been rather...
Oh, sorry.
Ah, has been rather shy about it.
And Miran has avoided the conversation altogether.
I have to look to...
How is that, like, pronounced?
Ki or Ti Luang for support.
He promised to help, but only if I beat him.
In Majong, which is entirely unfair.
Hopefully with the help of a cute kitty, I might be able to
cheat.
Sometimes being a little devious is okay, especially if it's
for the greater good.
Like art.
We're cheating in Majong?
Wait, where's the kitty?
Leish air.
What the?
Oh, that's unusual.
So the photo is acting a bit weird.
A little bit?
It's difficult to...
Kitty bottom, right?
Froggy bottom left?
Oh!
Whoa!
Kitty?
Welcome back!
A little too soon for my liking, but happy to have you.
Seems like the simulation had some difficulty maintaining
itself.
Tripping again for Rio.
We might need to reroute our power sources to keep Keep it
running.
Bummer.
Well, that's what we get for messing with old tech.
This is the old tech.
We'll get it sorted and then it's off to the races with you.
Is that...
Oh my gosh, wait, that's Jesse right there.
We can see a little bit of her head.
Who knew it'd be this tricky to get ancient tech back in
working order?
Just look at all this junk lying around.
Don't be cruel, Jesse.
These people were trailblazers.
could find a real tree of life in there or is it more
accurate to call it a lightning rod well either way one
thing's clear the weather disruptor really might be the
game-changer we need weather disruptor we're changing the
weather our world the red world oxygen rates continue to
fluctuate as a new wave of industry expansion begins dr.
Mirren Morrison an associate studied the climate and its
potential via a simulation weather disruptor notes and old
articles allude to a machine that could impact the weather
blueprints might be in the simulation oh these
are them with the growing industrial expansion sky rises
continue to pierce the red clouds with no sign of rain in
sight oxygen levels continue to fluctuate drastically and
citizens citizens are required to continue regular upkeep on
of indoor oxygen monitors the recommended values for oxygen
saturation are listed below when exiting isolation please
regard personal oxygen levels if assistance is required
contact the department of health and atmospheric conditions
for further assistance that reminds me of this reminds me of
like when you ride taxis in japan some of them will have
like the oxygen or it's like the how do you say it's like
the Yeah.
The cleanliness of the air.
Yeah, the air quality.
Sorry.
The air quality.
And it'll be like, good.
Perfect.
Bad.
Yeah, yeah.
These pictures are kind of creepy, though.
So we're looking for this guy.
Okay, so that's why we're in the simulation going through
all this stuff.
Interesting.
Okay.
Whoa.
We live in hell!
Oh my god.
The red clouds.
They didn't mention the red fog and the red mist and the
red...
The flames?
Air quality bad.
Very, very bad.
Everybody walks through tunnels.
You can't go outside.
They live on Mars.
I'm sanitizing my hands.
Ooh.
online no lab checks
it looks like like Gatorade kind of looks delicious though
right nice work looks like we're back online ready when you
are you couldn't have done that Jesse you couldn't have done
that well oh my eyes Oh my eyes!
Looks like Blade Runner, yeah!
Orange Gatorade.
Yeah, it's kind of like an orange drink.
Ah, just as stunning as I remember it.
Return to the Hogwarts.
And find where we left off.
Okay.
I remember the chocolate.
Yeah, we went to here.
Wait, there's a cat bed up there.
There really is a cat around here.
Where can I find the cat?
Where can I...
How can I get to the cat?
Okay.
I can see why they would stay here all the time, though,
if...
Damn, it's the door G-Man walks through.
Cat on bottom, right?
Sento Sencha a few minutes ago Oh, it's currently 2 a.m.
here But could I get a happy birthday from Minto?
I'm sorry that's only for the start of stream Oh, no, you're
okay!
Raiden Marmalade, happy birthday!
Sorry I missed it!
Happy, happy birthday!
Thank you, Darko.
Hmm.
And then we went over here.
Yeah, this is where it got all funky fresh.
All right.
But it's being weird again, though.
Photos are back to normal too.
Excellent.
Are they?
Because...
Should be smooth sailing from here.
That's the same photo.
That's the same photo over and over again.
There's something I need to do with it?
Trippy, right?
I know.
This is where I got it.
Whoa!
Build a bridge, but to where?
Unless I ruined it.
Maybe there was something over here.
Ah, I see, I see.
Oh, my teleporter was destroyed.
Oh, okay.
I have to be careful of that.
Whoopsie-poopsie.
I was going the wrong way.
I was doing the right thing, but I was going the wrong way.
With it.
What if I did that?
There we go.
What's this?
Stop messing with the teleporter.
You made it.
It's not that difficult.
Minky, look out there's a funky guy in the corner.
It is freaky though in here.
So I guess, I'm guessing, everybody who made this is either
dead or really old or something.
Close your eyes.
I don't know if I should.
Is this payback for making you mix new soil compositions all
day?
Please, Hiraya, have you ever known me to be the vengeful
sword?
Hmm.
Okay, see you.
Okay.
They were all very Nakayoshi.
A drawing!
Thank you, man.
That lovely eyebrows.
I was really sick.
I'm sitting there.
Oh, no!
Thank you!
I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry I missed it.
Thank you, thank you.
You don't have to send a super chat, though.
Whoa, this is weird.
It even sounds like drawing.
It's marvelous.
See?
I told you.
Whoa!
more paintings whoa so cool the colors how long did this
date you now that would be telling art should retain some
mystery though I don't oh wow the background even here we'll
go to cartoon world my god
wait this is so cute When I walk and jump, it makes sense.
What?
This is so cute!
I like it.
That's the glove!
You, I found it.
Now this was a funny one.
Meep, meep.
Roadrunner cartoon.
Not your usual style.
So I was stretching my creative muscles.
F-aligned photo.
Oh, interesting.
We're on the paper now.
Look at this sign!
It's so cute!
Oh, we're going into the video game.
Whoa!
Does this kill the bitrate?
Quick question.
Whoa!
Your mind is limitless.
This was fun.
Few things make me happier than when you say that here.
Not too bad.
Well, to be fair, it's quite crunchy for me too.
I gotta get up there, but...
How do they expect me to?
I didn't see a picture.
The crayons.
Pull the chain?
I guess I could try that, huh?
Oh yeah, you're so right.
Oh, the lever crunk.
The picture looks so weird here.
That's so fun.
Back to black and white.
Nice!
I still wonder how... Oh, wait, we're back here with a
chocolate, no?
Yeah, chocolate bar.
Is this new?
Teleport to next level.
Teleport to optional challenge.
Wait, I want to see the challenge.
No, what are we doing here?
Oh my god.
A crime scene.
Oh.
Yeah, I never back down from a challenge.
Whoa.
Oh.
We have to rotate it.
Which way?
This way?
Wow!
Okay, you don't know which way to rotate it until you do.
So let's see.
Oh, uh-huh.
Is there one on here, though?
This is neat, right?
There is one!
Oh, maybe they lead to each other.
Oh!
Maybe I was wrong?
You don't know until you do, exactly.
What the heck?
The sound of the grass makes me feel like something's
chasing after me.
Got a m- a monduck.
Okay.
Do I have to parkour over to somewhere or...
Oh, oops.
Maybe I needed to...
get this...
up somewhere.
Yeah, I think I need to rewind.
But kind of far, huh?
Oh no!
Wait, where do I need to go?
Where do
I need to place this is my question.
Maybe up there?
Wait.
No, no, no.
Huh?
No!
I think I placed it where I can't.
Oh, no.
I just so poorly placed it.
Okay.
Oh my god, there's like an invisible wall.
It won't even let me try on the sides or something.
It's pushing me away!
And there's no sprint.
Could you rewind all the way back?
It would take forever, no?
Oh, you can double tap R.
Oh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, maybe this makes it easier.
Which one was it?
This one, I guess?
Okay.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Oh, wait.
I lied.
It's not okay.
I still gotta do one more.
I still have to do one more!
There we go.
Okay.
Ah!
Yeah, you have to strategize with the photos.
It's nice, though.
They realize this, I think.
Wait, can we get back up?
Yes.
So that's why I think they allow you to go back so far.
Like, some things you wouldn't know unless, like...
Unless you went through it already, if that makes sense.
Maybe here?
Wait.
There we go.
Where was I trying to get it to again?
Oh,
I destroyed it in trying to get back to it.
Yeah, I erased everything.
Whoopsie-poopsie.
Let's try here?
Maybe?
Oh,
I'm not high enough.
I'm guessing that...
Up here is where I need to get to, that's what I've been
trying to anyway.
Can you angle the last picture upwards?
Yeah, that's what I'm trying to do.
What if I like...
Maybe like that.
Oh yeah.
But I don't think this is a great...
Wait!
Oh it is!
Oh it's so perfect!
okay now i have no the thing about this game is you might
accidentally destroy the thing that you need and you never
know because now i'm wondering was i even supposed to get up
here was i did i accidentally destroy the place that we were
trying to get to and i have no idea oh shoot
not too much creative freedom well let's just for now let's
just uh we'll We'll continue the...
We'll continue the game.
Oh, look at my duckies!
Wait, this is like a home base, I guess.
Oh, fine!
Okay.
Yeah, because it has revisit levels and...
I remember getting stuck on this level, too.
Really.
Soundtrack is so...
nice let's keep going all right so we need two batteries
what is this fix try not to break it again not my fault a
photocopier okay that
was easy um That was easy enough.
For a second, the stream audio had doubled, but it was
actually a cat outside my window whining in the same tone
and frequency.
What does that mean?
What?
Wait a second.
Is that... Oh, it must be.
A photocopier.
Hey.
Ducky.
Yay!
We found all the ducks.
Oh, find all the ducks in chapter one.
On second thought, why don't I write this one down?
Did you just shift reality?
Wait, write what down?
What did we write down?
What do you mean?
Why did you record that?
Why did you record?
yourself saying I better write this down and then you
didn't.
Is that where I need to go?
Wait.
I think I need to make a copy of this one.
I'm not, I won't say I'm a huge fan of the the voice acting
work but you know it's still the kitty!
The cat in the game is very cute.
Oh, you're so cute!
You're like spaghetti.
I'm hungry.
Water doesn't need to have a smell.
I couldn't stop thinking about this while watching Hiraya
tend to her plants today.
There's an addictive quality to this place that makes up for
the inaccuracies that surround us when we come here.
Out of thin air, we create beauty that tickles some, but not
all of our senses.
Strictly speaking, the code we create is a technical marvel
in designing new structures thrills me like nothing else.
But the novelty of it all makes it too easy to forget what a
real flower smells like.
And I don't want to forget prototype number four.
Interesting.
Wait, how would I even get there, though?
How would I get to...
Wait, I made it too far away?
I made it too far away?
Wait.
Oh, he's following me!
Oh.
Quantum cat!
What's Minto's favorite flower?
Hydrangea.
Oh, I saw him.
I saw him.
Oh, I saw him!
I saw him!
There he is.
Yeah, you see him appear.
You see him appear.
How can I get to there, though?
Hmm.
Oh, maybe...
Like that or something?
What?
Sometimes it's so hard to tell what the perspective is.
Ah!
Oopsie.
Maybe up like that.
There we go.
One step.
Oh.
Yeah, yeah, there we go.
going i wonder what else is no what's that
jesse's never seen a train before where does it stop
actually though oh over here
oh thank you i must admit i'm surprised you meet it this far
it's been a while since someone's wandered around this place
the cat is talking to have you there's plenty of things to
do here oh it's kate katelyn you're not the train will take
us to heraya's station a place where science and art meet
nature can i put the cat zero out of ten game there we go
next Hands and legs inside the vehicle.
All the lovely artistic elements you see are all thanks to
his handiwork.
Though his colleagues were just as amazing in their own.
Ride the train.
Your work was always said to change the world.
Or so they said.
Often.
Ascend.
I'm Kate, by the way.
Caitlin.
An artificial record keeper.
Developed by millions to maintain this place.
Caitlin, are you okay?
I'm here to assist you in any way that I can.
forward to seeing what wonders you discover Caitlin, why are
you shaking like that?
You're scaring me.
Wow, it's so pink.
Wow.
Glad to find out.
That's how they go around.
Pink fish.
The floor.
Whoa.
These are sick.
I wonder if they found him.
You had a rock.
Okay.
Yeah, um, where's my applause?
I live for the applause, applause, applause.
Dread Mangle!
She is so quirky.
She'd be a great streamer.
Oh my gosh, she left and didn't even do her dishes.
Is that a tree?
It's beautiful.
I had to check twice to make sure it was actually pink.
Hey!
Imagine seeing something like this every day.
I've seen trees like this before, though, right?
There are trees.
I can't remember what they're called, but there are trees
that are, like, colorful like this.
I just can't remember.
Does anyone remember what they're called?
They're so awesome.
Just pink.
I don't think it's sycamore.
I don't look at it.
Jesse don't you need to go cook oh
I guess it's maybe a rainbow eucalyptus yeah yeah some
people said it too yeah the rainbow eucalyptus if you look
it up like heavily flammable them all in all in all i'm just
another tile on the floor what is that a what is that a
reference to oh wow they look crazy right right nature is
fun nature's so awesome so cool
so yeah maybe that's where she's inspired oh no why would
you put these in here the Poopal plant.
Oh, I can hear the flies.
Hiraia is a psychopath.
What the heck is wrong with you?
And so many of them.
This place reeks.
It's terrible.
Is that hers?
We had Picasso up in here.
Drawing everybody.
There is no smell.
I guess they did say that.
That they...
But they were like, I don't want to forget the smell of how
a flower smells.
Dried mango.
This must be the next set.
Yep.
Cool.
Oh wow, another pers- oh, her own perspective thing.
I'll never take the art of walking into your work for
granted.
What?
I don't even do that.
Whoa!
Oh, oh, here too, here too.
Nice one.
Uh-huh.
That's weird.
Uh-oh.
Sorry, the simulation is really buggy on my end.
I'm just gonna- oh good.
See you later, Jesse.
We can handle it.
We'll- we'll take care of it.
We don't need your commentary.
It's okay.
got this.
Oh, hi.
Hi, Caitlin.
This reminds me of Mancala.
I want to play Mancala.
Wait.
Jesse is blasting off again?
Hello?
Oh, thank God.
You answered.
No!
It's me.
I don't know how it happened, but somehow I lost direct
communication with you.
Live comms don't seem to be working where you are.
That should be fine, though.
We can talk using this method, as long as you pick up.
I'll try to leave voicemails if you can't.
Okay.
I've been monitoring your vitals in the system.
Bring these to the planning session.
Good luck in there.
Show diagram 121C to Aeron.
He'll laugh hard enough to wet himself.
I found a banana magnet.
Ah, these are interesting.
Yeah, voicemails it is.
And I like that they're a lion on creativity.
Have you ever seen that picture of the crazy stairs?
This game gives me the crazy stairs, bud.
I'll make sure to keep an eye on it and see how this
experiment might be.
I agree.
Leave the phone off the hook, I beg.
Everybody doesn't like Jesse.
I'm starting to feel bad.
Alright, let's see.
What do we do here?
Gamers don't look up.
Gamers do look up and see nothing.
Gamers can't climb.
Is there something that I can interact with?
Wow, look at the mountains!
Wow!
She is annoying!
I am too, you guys, but you're here still.
Oh, what's this?
All your hard work has led to this moment.
We're going to change the world.
Oh!
What is it?
Wait.
I could draw anything.
Oh wait, there's a picture right here.
I'm so... Oh wait, it's more mountains.
Oh, I thought it would eat it.
There we go.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think I'm doing it.
And then it grows.
Wow
That I learned from Metal Gear Solid 2 You would never know
I touched it That's kind of crazy All it takes is one seed
These are very I'm getting vibes of my mother And she would
like have these sticky notes everywhere and things like
that.
Nito cute!
Jesse's throwing out more 2007 than 2007.
I've never contained your love, Jesse.
You don't need to be the clown all the time.
That's so true.
It's so true.
Maybe they want you to do it over here.
Instead.
They want you to do it on that side instead.
Okay, game.
Oh, come on.
There's a wall in my way.
Just perfect.
Looking at the list of A words for Minto.
I see amazing, awesome, adorable, not seeing annoying blue.
Where are we at?
There we go.
all right yeah a bit rude game oh there we go nice wait my
math oh gosh all my hard work my life's work my afterlife's
work seeing you walk around this place brings back memories
where are you oh gosh you blend right in kitten cat little
kitten let me pet you I'm gonna get you.
You can pet the cat!
Never mind.
10 out of 10.
I was gonna say this is not the type of game that would make
it like you can't pet the cat.
At some point we must realize that what we build with our
hands is not enough.
But to truly bring something to life, we must breathe life
into it ourselves.
There is no life in calculations on a board.
It sounds like somebody trying to sound like an old lady.
But there is life in our hands.
Like when I talk like this.
The way we care.
I am.
This reminds me of Zoom Beanie's.
Ooh, brainstorming.
How to use our screen printing and mural successes.
orchards mirin dream big but remain practical paradox these
smart folks i'm all i'm already 30 years old sounds like
elastigirl to me oh maybe maybe maybe i'm hearing it wrong
then there i had to code by by a by a by a look happy.
I'll paint her a Bagris tree anyway.
Potential colors for Hiroya's Bagris tree.
So we need green.
Pink and green and blue.
Create a world.
Oh, what's this?
Thank goodness for sensible ideas.
is guide tagged along for the meeting you mean the
outrageously handsome guy with the killer dress sense I take
it back why are they communicating through sticky notes
Caitlin where are you speaking from always a pleasure to
watch a master at work breathtaking paint me next
thought-provoking where did he'd say that from?
Yes, my form is amazing, he says.
It did sound above me.
But I think he was right here.
Okay, so there's one more lever somewhere?
Oh!
Ain't that funny?
Oh.
How do I align it perfectly?
Whoa.
Trippy.
Somewhere.
Gamers don't look down.
Wait, but I didn't use my deck of cards for...
Oh, there he is.
Hi, Caitlin.
Caitlin, what do I use this for?
Can I pick one up?
Stab.
Wait.
Oh, it's actually just like...
an item now put down both playing cards I fold oh you just
get an achievement for it okay that's fun it's all about
perspective oh we're back home okay neat we went through
that one this is the next one we're just going down the
this game must have some serious skips maybe kaylin what are
you doing up there that's where i need to be you're not
making this any easier for me what are you doing right here
oh baby what is this
oh where did you go why didn't you say that Oh, why did she
say that to me right here?
Melon pine!
There I, uh...
Oishi melon pine.
Oh.
Oh, well, actually that might work.
Oh, I can't move it anyway.
Never mind, I can't move it.
I guess we'll take the other one, though.
I've been...
running these biochar experiments for a few days now every
time i think i finally achieve the perfect soil composition
and nutrition as soon as i mimic future climate conditions i
don't hear elastic girl what falls apart it's a kind of do
but don't but not enough to slow me down there must be
something i'm missing maybe maybe i can talk to mirin about
it.
Oh.
Are you in the photo?
You're not.
You're not even in there.
Excellent shot.
Thanks.
So sad.
These are fun.
Now we get to take our own photos.
Specimen B, visible growth.
Control specimen, no change.
I think if...
Is this the best way to be taking logs?
Specimen B, stalled growth.
Control specimen, no change.
Metabolic flux conversion.
Risky but acetate synthesis is ideal.
Back to the drawing board.
Increasing biochar doses to prep for restart.
Definitely not.
Low acetate levels?
Question mark, question mark, question mark.
Improvement.
Back down to one dose to maintain root quality.
Oh, dang it.
I did it again.
Oops.
I...
Oh, but it's supposed to be.
It's, again, it's fixed, so...
Oh my gosh.
Hardcore champions.
over here I feel like Chilong but I have a solution to this
Chilong this mess of my own making he must know what Mira
has been working on squirreled away in her own little corner
maybe I can find a way to help that might put us back on
good terms what happened Mending relationships often felt
harder for her eye than tending to her plans.
I wonder why she always put in the effort despite that.
I don't know, AI kitty.
I don't know.
Oh, you're here too.
What can I pick up?
Oh, I got an orange.
Oh, don't lose that.
I got an orange magnet.
Nice.
I think I can make this.
Yeah.
Oh, that was close.
Wait, there's another one?
Where's the other one at?
I didn't accidentally delete it again, did I?
Wait, where could it be?
What stuff have we got?
I have a bunch of these.
Like, it won't let me move it.
So this is how they want me to do it.
Can I go high in the air?
Is it like up there maybe?
This also looks like a walking area.
I can make it.
Trust.
Yes.
Everybody trusted, right?
Where do I need to go?
Wait a second.
I have a vantage point.
Hi, Kitty.
I have a vantage point and nowhere to go.
I don't think I see one up there.
Can you take pictures of the battery?
Well, I guess I could move it there, huh?
It could be...
Okay.
That's so true.
Wait, did I use up all of these?
Yes.
We got one shot, baby.
Wait, where'd all my photos go?
Wait, they're out of my inventory now.
Wait, okay, now they're back in my inventory now.
Like that, maybe.
Yeah, one is all we need.
Oh!
It's going to be...
Whoa!
Yay!
Thanks, Caitlin.
It worked!
Oh.
Not that I mind the company.
On the contrary, really.
So cute.
I find you to be quite adventurous and fun.
I have a job to do.
All right.
A game?
I remember this.
Araya once told me that there's power in nurturing
something.
Oh!
I am uncertain by what she meant.
But you seem to have a handle on things.
Oh my gosh!
It's a Tomagachi!
It's a...
Wait, it's actually just Tomodachi.
More water.
What's this one do?
More sun?
Grow nice and big, guy.
How do I save it?
Oh!
Can we keep the frog as a crosshair?
I don't think we should, probably.
Vod friend skip ahead one hour.
What are you talking about?
I'm it looks like it has like a little face Oh wait, you
can't see because of the frog, but it's like oh No
It hates music.
It hates music This has to be part of the game
More Sun more Sun more Sun more Sun Grow grow be happy Why
do you hate music?
I think I'm overwatering it.
Oh!
Pickle, pickle.
Pickle, pickle, pickle, pickle.
No!
Or...
It's drowning.
If this is what that one scientist lady meant by doing
advanced soil research, I want my college Tuition back.
Guys, I think it's over.
I think it's over.
Yes!
If I could turn back time.
If I could find a way.
La la la la la la la
la.
It'll never
Hurry Sun Sun Sun Sun Oh no Water butter water water barter
butter water water water water Sun Sun Sun son bear La la la
la la la la
Water Frogboard get his government mandate a 30 minute break
Oh we're so back we're so back Pick up pick up Sun Water?
Watch this.
We got the flower!
Now he's watching me grow.
It died in front of me!
Wait a second.
This is tough.
This is a hard game.
Oh,
okay, okay.
I give up.
Where are we going?
Oh.
Oh, Kaylin.
Alrighty.
You stay.
You stay good.
No.
Or don't.
I don't care.
Do whatever you want to do.
He blends in.
I think we use this to take a picture of this.
Or we now do this.
Uh-oh.
Oh, I messed it up.
Which way is it first?
This way?
Yeah.
But it has no film!
What do I do?
We're in the past feeding it now.
Wait, if it has no film...
no... Is it because... Wait.
Is it because this one has no film?
No, it has one.
Oh, I guess it took a picture of this one which has no film.
Uh-oh.
Wait, do I need to... Uh-oh.
I think I need to go back in time.
If I could turn back time.
If I could find a world...
Oh, my flower is healthy.
It's dying even more.
I believe in big brain meato.
You should, you should.
Oh, wait.
It's not...
Yeah, this is the right way.
Yeah.
Oh.
Well, um...
Probably fine.
Sorry, Mr. Kitten.
Oh.
you should you should believe in big brain me the oh we're
back here right our magnets our magnets I was being genuine
earlier I'd like to help you look the fenders left plenty of
records of their work here in case they were to ever come
back.
I wonder.
Well, I hope it'll be of some use to you.
Now I have Minto going La la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la la la
stuck in my head.
She's haunting my ear drums.
It reminds me oh my gosh.
I was watching.
So they've been uploading Detective Conan movies on to
YouTube and I was watching the seventh movie.
wait is that it was it the seventh one
am i a fake fan Conan seventh movie yes I was right
crossroad in the ancient capital you can watch them for free
and I watched the seventh one recently and uh seventh how
many are there like oh gosh I think like 20 now or something
Detective Conan Movies.
They started in, like, 1997, and they've done one every year
since.
So, you tell me how many movies there are.
There's, like, at least 20.
I think they're up to...
It was, like, almost...
Maybe 29 or something.
yeah but um of like the main movies that's not like counting
the spin-off movies and stuff but um this year would make 30
like that's crazy um but uh i was watching the seventh movie
it's really good it's really good the movies are so fun i i
highly recommend them especially free on youtube um and uh
one of the main characters ron she's like the girl if you
watch case close you might know her as rachel but um ron
she's thinking of she which one second
i'm spotting the tiniest bug i've ever seen hold on i'm
gonna smush it like it's so tiny i can't even pick it up
like i couldn't even get it and release it like it's just so
small what if it grows up into a wasp i must get it
anyway um the main girl ron is thinking of shinti which if
you watched case close you might know him as jimmy jimmy
kudo which is The adult version of Conan.
Okay, so Conan.
If you don't know anything about Conan.
Conan, little kid.
But he's not actually a little kid.
He was fed a poison that was supposed to kill him.
But it actually shrunk his body.
And so, Ron is childhood friends with Shinji.
And she's always like, Shinji, where are you?
Where are you?
And he's like, sorry, I'm on some case.
He can't tell her that he shrunk his body to a little kid
and lives in her house now and takes baths with her because
that would be weird.
And also he probably is more concerned about her getting
caught by the organization that fed him the poison, APTX
poison.
The longest con.
Yeah, the men in black, the black organization is the ones
that are after him.
But anyway, Ron likes Shinti.
She is in rubble with him.
But in the seventh movie, every time she would think about
him, she would go, or not she, but there was like a
background.
There was a background music that would play that would go.
And so I can't stop doing it.
I can't stop going.
Suddenly, suddenly what?
Your fascination with the series is starting to make more
sense.
What do you mean by that?
So much wind up for this story.
I had to give context of Conan.
Because Conan is a trip, man.
It's so...
Why?
Why'd she leave in a hurry?
Oh, hello.
And I, the way I sing it, it does sing like la la la la la
in the movie, but also the way that I sing.
Oh, drop a battery off the level.
the way I sing it is similar to the opening of a show called
Nanalan do you guys know Nanalan it's like a little it's a
baby show for babies like quite literally but it's about
this little girl named Nanalan and her and her just
adventures and stuff and the opening goes la la la la
la la and so I've been la lying to everything recently
because Because I watched the Conan and the la la la la song
reminded me of Nanalan opening and it goes la la la la la la
and so I'm always thinking of Nanalan because I don't know
what's wrong with that girl.
There's something wrong with her and her dog.
So she sees bubbles and she goes like.
No, that's another dog.
But the dog is really freaky.
Now I can get both.
Brilliant, gosh.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I love these little peaks in the Minto's mind.
It's just how I'm thinking.
La, la, la.
And so I've been la-la-ing everything recently, and
everything is like that, like, tone.
That, la.
Just like the...
or the little music box.
The radio with the Tomagot.
No, no, no.
It's okay.
We don't have to pick up.
Nanalan, watch along.
When?
JK, please don't.
Don't the leaves look off to you, Raya?
I can't tell anymore.
It actually stopped.
We've been saved.
The problem isn't that my plants are dying.
It's that they don't die without being told to do so.
set foot in this place to find a dead flower awaiting my
return the results of my experiments live in the dozens of
lot of file archives I've made here I'm handing over all
documentation of soil failures to Qi Lung so they can see
the bigger picture as usual I fear my best work will only
show itself in my conclusion Qi Lung is my hope that this
won't have to be the case a world just isn't a world without
cycles we can't control not so true I learned on Nanoland
from a YouTube compilation of Nanoland episodes slowed down
at 0.5 speed and it's the funniest thing ever.
It's like already a trip of a shoal.
It is.
It's very, it's very funky and funny.
I think I needed to not use that just yet.
Improved biofiltration designs.
Thank you for sharing all your soil sample code.
Oh no!
I cut it off!
That's okay though.
That's okay.
Um...
We need one or two.
Let's see.
Oh, we need two of them.
Wait, that's not okay because I... Okay, wait, I do need the
photo.
I do need the photo first.
We're free!
Okay.
Take the photo.
I love perspective puzzles.
They're so fun.
Alright, and since that breaks that...
Maybe...
I'll take another photo and we can get a second one.
Okay, take you.
And now I need these out of the way, because I think they'll
be...
They'll be destroyed by this one.
Okay.
I mean, I guess I didn't have to do it right there, but...
Whatever.
Oh, if it works, it works.
Yeah.
Nice.
There's something satisfying about tilting her head in such
a way and having everything click.
Yeah!
I wonder if she was right.
But that's not what you're looking for.
A machine to control the climate.
Where is it?
Power that would be.
Oh, they have...
Oh.
Where did she have it?
Wait, I didn't find the magnet in this level.
Oh, well.
That's fine.
Optional challenge.
Sitting on the headphones.
Headed to oblivion.
Do I go to the next place?
Was that everything here?
Shall we continue forward?
Oh, I think so, yeah, right?
Yeah!
We're heading towards the workspace of a masterful engineer.
I wonder how long it takes to...
Much like the others, settled in quickly here.
Beat this game.
The batteries, the teleporters, that's all thanks to his
handiwork.
Who's talking to me?
Though, he wouldn't accept the compliment directly.
Where are you?
Are you up here?
Oh, Caitlin!
I'm sure you'll find something useful here.
One step closer to solving an impossible question.
Blue is blue.
Dabadi, dabadi.
The voice is in my head, yeah.
Well,
this one's like a workshop workshop.
Information, information!
Gosh, this guy is all about learning information, isn't he?
More information.
No, the Majang!
And the chocolates.
He's a knower.
Yeah.
Cool area though.
I like it.
Whoa.
Wow.
He's getting ripped in the digital world.
Digital.
Digimon.
There's more up here.
Whoa!
There's so many levels on this one.
I said my piece.
Looking back, these last few sessions have been the most
difficult.
And the most fun I've had since I can remember.
Every corner of this place is an expression of some dream
one of us had.
That's gotta be something, right?
Kind of like a stored piece of memory.
Just like Mirren's photographs.
The digital circus.
No, Jax, you're gonna abstract!
Don't abstract yourself, Jax!
I have to ask my Oshi.
I haven't been able to talk to her about...
Filter Select.
About digital circus.
She really loves it.
Someone's laughing.
It's kind of creepy.
Hello?
Do you hear that?
In my memories, I hear singing and laughing.
Silent Hill.
I remember a celebration.
In my memories, I see that laughter.
Should we go take a look?
Yeah, hold on, I gotta get to it, buddy.
I'm pulling the lever.
What does it make?
Oh, a bridge, okay.
Whoa!
Did you freaking shift reality, you mother freaker?
You freaking mother freaker shifting reality, freaker freak.
I can't freaking believe you've freaking shifted reality.
Well done.
Thank you.
It's a shame things crumble over time.
Actually, oh, I just realized we didn't pick up the phone.
First Celion, now you.
you yeah i miss my cat so much that cake looks delicious
hope
there's an achievement for not answering the phone isn't it
incredible we're winding to get the perfect show too much of
that cannot be good for my health hi it's your birthday hi
no problem all the eating and drinking and dancing lots of
dancing i even bought my guitar to play for you that's a
high honor you know all right all right happy birthday to me
that's more like it no take a bow
whoa what's that wait oh we need three of them okay or two
more happy birthday that's wonderful It's so meaningful.
I love these little events.
Oh, it looks so good!
If my system memory is correct, Celion received quite a
unique gift that day.
A camera?
Is it this?
Oh.
Oh, you found it!
A camera.
Whoa!
Contable and with instant film to boot.
Wow!
And a powerful way to store data.
wait to see how you use this i'd use it myself if i had
thumbs well i'm just gonna start making uh copies of
everything at the moment doink look at this now i have extra
batteries
so many what's that sound
more wishes.
I keep doubling.
I don't know if the, if the, wait, I couldn't bring the
camera?
No way!
Oh no, that sucks.
Aw man.
My camera.
Oh, I do, okay.
It does reset.
This camera physics thing that Mirren has proposed is going
on.
make me nauseous gravity exists for a reason sounds like
someone's just a big old baby
oh i watched the cup drop that's so funny
diagram of a camera oh ah ha ha feel a bit feeling a bit
turned around so which way should we do it then of It
wouldn't be this way.
So this way?
Can I make it?
Here I go!
Ah!
Oh yeah!
We have to parkour over there or something?
Maybe?
Oh, uh, yeah, yeah.
We could always take another photo.
That's so true.
Oh wait, I...
I'm so dumb.
I didn't...
I didn't... I'm so stupid.
Wait.
Put it here and then we take a picture of the thing.
I'm so silly.
There we go.
Duh.
You.
Alright, there we go.
Yeah.
I'm silly.
Oh, she is so far away.
Maybe we should pick up at least once.
Let her know that we're still alive, you know?
Or, I can complete the puzzle.
I can complete...
Let's listen to her voicemail.
Oh, wait.
If I go listen to this, I don't think I'll be coming back.
Hey, another voicemail.
reach you i hope you're doing well i've been doing my best
to track your movements it's been difficult though possibly
some sort of error on my part yeah i must be you not me i'm
going to reach out again soon try to answer next time if you
can despite this mess i know you'll be fine
thanks anyway
uh can i actually not get back up there
Where did I put this?
Oh, here.
The subtitles were different, weren't they?
Alright, and the film does restart.
I've been waiting for you.
Hi!
So cute.
I miss my kitty.
What is this?
Dustin!
Most elusive indeed.
No bully.
Was that the only reason you came here?
Oh.
Whoa, whoa.
Oh, wait, what is this?
Pick up Dustin.
Oh, if I'm on top of Dustin and I pick him up, it gets all
freaky.
Come on.
What are these?
Ooh.
Put Caitlin on Dustin.
I don't think I can.
I can put I could put Dustin on Caitlyn.
Wait, if Caitlyn's not there anymore, what happens?
Oh.
Nice.
Caitlyn is always there.
So what are we trying to do here?
Hoi!
Hardcore.
Up to there.
And then maybe like...
Oh, so close.
What if I did like that?
There we go.
Feels a bit silly to have stairs in here.
It keeps you engaged.
I like it.
Wait, there were stairs?
Were there stairs?
Infinite Caitlyn's.
Caitlyn doesn't show up in the photo, though, sadly.
What?
Hang on, did you nick my biscuit?
My biscuit?
What sort of accusation is that?
You did, didn't you?
Zelda time!
Oh, right, so what if I did?
It was just sitting there going uneaten.
It's not as if it could have gone cold.
Well, if you're gonna kick up a fuss, Kate, can you please
run shortbread.exe for our esteemed colleague here?
Shortbread.exe!
See, Liam was always fond of games.
Is there anything else to do or am I crazy?
Computer, Jarvis, run Densatsu.exe.
And shortbread.exe, please.
Oh, I see it up there.
I wonder if we can...
Uh...
I gotta go in there.
Hold on.
Let's see if we can angle this bit more.
Does this angle it a bit more?
Uh...
Brain.exe win!
There's always brain.exe!
Oh, that doesn't...
That doesn't...
Oh, ah!
.exe.
Where did the brain.exe start?
Hey, me, don't chat.
I hope you're having a good stream.
Just got back from an evening out.
I hope you had fun, Jembo!
Let's do it from here then.
Wait.
I got it, I got it!
Got him!
Landed on the cat.
I wouldn't want anything else.
You think in a simulation everyone will find a way to
maintain itself, but no.
It's fine.
Keeps me busy.
Some peace and quiet.
I think we might need to be on the last patch.
Cat .exe.
I'm always cat.exe.
EXE.
All the time.
Never stopped being cat.exe.
Oh.
I think I can grab it.
Oh yeah.
This is weak sauce.
Watch this.
Wait.
I'm going to take a picture of it first.
Watch this.
It's a good thing.
I think I took a picture of it, huh?
Watch this.
Why is the thermos so powerful?
Why is the thermos the only thing that couldn't get knocked
over?
Did you know that scientists have to spend years developing
a master?
before they're often allowed to share their work.
I'm gonna eat some...
peanut butter pretzels.
It's called the scientific method.
Keaton.
Pushing things off the shelf, falling down, cat.exe.
So yeah.
I just ordered Karage ramen!
And you didn't tell me!
Now I can't possess you and eat it!
stone why wouldn't you tell me oh I have to go upstairs wait
how did I get upstairs before oh here
that's the beauty of the simulation what what you can
achieve in a year's time can be merely a blank here though
that does make perfection I was often wary of that.
Can
you possess and stream at the same time?
Congrats on your 20 quid win.
Don't get used to it.
You're stuck.
Oh.
I don't think I took a picture of the right thing.
But...
Hold!
What if I take a picture like this?
I can't get through it.
Who would have thunk?
Oh nice.
There we go.
Stop right there and shout your guess.
Simapan!
20 quid says you can't guess what I made.
Oh, oh,
I guess it's still the same.
Completed my fastest build yet.
The code, beautiful.
I'm out of film!
Come see me when you finish your calculations.
These might be useful.
Yes, they will.
Thank you.
I'm working in Aluong's workspace today.
I've exiled myself to the opposite end to keep the bickering
to a minimum.
but a little sparse i like his other builds more i can hear
you get back to work fine i won't bother you anymore
verbally at least what's he mean by that verbally oh we got
the card wait that's fine
these things yeah he's gonna He's going to bother us
physically.
Well, I guess not us, her.
Hello, Caitlin.
We need two batteries.
We got one tile.
And we got one film.
Marin's extra piping for the seventh trial.
What is the seventh trial?
What are they doing here?
I can hear you're whining from all the way over here.
You know the notes what they remind me of?
They remind me of Outer Wilds.
The notes between the Nomai and Outer Wilds.
Now that I think about it.
Goodbye notes.
But I don't have any more film.
And still only one battery.
Hmm.
two TVs one original and one clone which TV is the real TV
all right fine you're winning me over I told you it would
random conversation from an ancient civilization I have a
knack for knowing the unknowable yeah yeah mate you're
bloody brilliant yeah since they're all scientists too right
just hearing you say that is enough of a reward for me wait
actually I do need your help doing the frog dance right now
let me show you you're being cagey lead the way professor oh
okay i see what i need to do i need to take a picture of
this and then have it connect so that i can grab both maybe
like that will that work will i be able to get back up let's
see
maybe i tilted it a little far Maybe just that is fine.
Hoi.
Oh.
Thank you, Minto.
Stay cool.
Thank you, Willie.
Gee, thank you.
Ten tank time flies.
Thank you, TJ.
Thank you for 10 months.
Thank you.
It does fly, doesn't it?
Wow.
Just next week, actually...
This one.
This one is quite complicated.
Is it?
Next week will be my six-year anniversary.
It's actually the day of Legends Anu.
Harai wants to meet for, and I quote, a friendly game of
Mahjong.
I told her I'd meet alone, as long as she bought food.
Pretending everyone's fine and dandy always works better
with food.
Why are things not fine and dandy?
to do next week.
Thank you!
See you then!
Yeah!
Yeah, it's pretty funny, right?
Why did you say this is complicated?
It's like...
Try duplicating K.
It's not that complicated.
Easy.
Minto gaming?
Two months left for my shining Ibu badge.
Yes!
Oh my gosh!
You will become rainbow and beautiful.
I mean, you're already beautiful, but you know.
Too easy for Minto.
Give me a challenge.
What?
What do you call a melon that commits a crime?
Evil.
A water felon.
Oh, that's been here.
He's got a knife!
A bloody knife.
Those we got in here.
We're all so creative.
Oh yeah, yeah.
I figured with this one, if we took a picture, it would like
sever this So we got to be careful about the photo we take.
Oh.
Thanks.
Oh, gosh.
I almost hit a mega, Caitlin.
That was scary.
That was terrifying.
I'll admit, this never gets old.
Oh, now it's more complicated.
Oh, I thought that was a safe.
What if I just take it from here?
Can I do that?
Oh, look at that.
Wait, before we do it, though, before we do it.
Before we do that, was there anything over here?
Oh, just a puddle.
Wee!
Oh, there's more stuff.
Oh, the camera doesn't break it.
Lever system works well.
Oh, okay.
No wonder her eye was angry.
Easy, easy.
Mirren's onto something.
I know it.
Oh.
But she's not the greatest person when dealing with others.
Mr. Cat, maybe the two of them could bond over a cat.
cat pet session or something.
I have heard petting me is quite soothing.
I bet.
Feel free to do it anytime.
Thank you.
I feel thoroughly soothed.
Why is it raining?
Wait.
I don't want to alarm anyone, but there's a dancing frog.
No way.
Where's the phone at?
Oh, here.
I guess I'll answer.
Oh, got it.
So, looking into this setup, there's clearly something wrong
with the system.
The deeper you go, the more the data are corrupt due to lack
of upkeep.
Meaning, you might have to find your own exit if that's the
case.
I think our goals stay the same.
Find the specs for the weather disruptor.
Get out.
Save the climate.
All that good stuff.
I'll reach out again when I can.
Hope you're messing with reality in some cool ways.
the data hmm yes i have noticed over time that in the later
sections of the simulation the degradation has gotten
progressively worse but isn't that true for all things that
once lived despite that it's still wondrous i hope you'll
feel that way too
what do you mean jesse i don't think she appreciates how
serious this what do you mean oh you're just gonna be stuck
in the simulation you're gonna have to find way out oh
no i have three photos do i have to like do you think i can
connect them is that too difficult some tiki energy for real
i'm sorry you're just gonna have to figure it out figure out
find your own exit she's so quirky and We love her!
I don't think I can.
I don't think I can connect them, right?
Hmm.
But maybe it's kind of a self-sacrificing.
Like, we find the specs and we just stay in here with
Caitlin.
I wouldn't mind that, too.
I mean...
Yeah, I guess that's fine, right?
Maybe I can...
Get along.
There we go.
Yeah!
Will Project Hail Mary the whole thing?
It's fine.
Check Hiraya's numbers.
Growth anomaly?
What's this?
Mint Tensai!
I know maybe like
here new
camera filter unlocked negative oh oh
there's no fall damage we're fine I pray that you've been
enjoying your explorations thus far yup oh i was gonna go
pet him but sure i think there's many memories stored here
many impossible things it acts as a record of sorts much
like a photo trap if it works it works so true i'm glad
there's someone new to experience it ah thanks kateline i
said the next level we have the world to save.
Literally.
Hiraia's perfected biochar.
What to do with this?
Hiraia's final observations.
Oh no, so she's gone.
She probably is not gone, gone.
Like she's left.
Most likely.
Oh, neat.
Is modeling miniatures a good use of your time?
Your meditation nook?
If by meditation you mean build the body of everyone's
dreams.
Okay, buddy.
Alright.
I need this guy.
I'm going to need this guy to pack it up here.
What if I just do this?
It's because it stays on.
Oh, it needs to be powered.
Wait, but it's powered here.
What are we talking about?
Oh.
Yeah, speed timer.
I guess let's try this.
And then...
That?
There we go.
Really gets your heart pumping.
Well, if you have one, of course.
He's like, you can see inside me.
I am all noodles.
Where are the plans for the weather machine?
Oh, this one's actually interesting.
Just a noodley guy, a noodley little boy.
Man.
Hmm.
Maybe I can get up top and take a photo?
Or something?
Maybe not.
But maybe not.
Maybe I can like...
Hmm.
Wait.
No.
Imagine.
The tree is ruining my vibe.
Oh wait.
Maybe that photo was fine though.
Let's do...
Does this Does this even work?
No.
Let's try.
Now this is just Universe making fun of me.
Fifth stream I decided to watch.
And again, this is like a lucid dream.
Wait, what?
Huh?
Hello?
What do you- Wait, what?
I'm confused.
Okay, I thought that this was a powering.
A power thing.
This is pretty fast.
Alright, so we just gotta do the same thing as before.
I'm out of camera film!
I have one photo.
Oh, wait.
But I got...
It's still sideways, though.
So it has to be of this.
But does it matter...
if it's powered or not oh oh that's fine okay so it still
works like that okay good we learn yeah overthinking is
there any reason you're so reluctant to have good designs
whoa sarcastic much i enjoy good designs efficiency over
beauty huh there is beauty and efficiency you just have to
understand it Ah, yeah.
What a lovely way to phrase that.
Very wise to you, Long.
Oh, I want ramen.
I want ramen real bad.
Yummy, yummy, yummy.
Doraia's final observations.
Oh, it's the auto-vac.
Wait, we can make it?
We can construct the auto-vac.
Get Romina off, Kai?
Maybe.
Oh no, Dustin!
What a cursed creature!
Did he just hiss at this thing?
It makes me want to chase it a bit.
Dude, thank you!
We need to vibrate higher so we can capture the opening of
the portal that connects this earth of 3D to the one of 40
or 5D.
Going to be 5D.
I can vibrate really fast.
I can do it really, really fast.
Want to watch?
I'm feeling it.
I'm feeling the 5D.
Did we make it?
Did we jump dimensions?
Oh, man.
We just went back to the dimension where it's the Bernstein
Bears.
Ugh.
I went to the wrong one!
You mean burn stain?
No!
We're now in the timeline where it's the burn stain!
I actually don't remember which is which.
I don't remember if it's supposed to be the burn stain bears
or burn stain bears.
I don't remember.
What was I doing?
Oh yeah, we were making a bridge.
Check this out.
Oops.
How did I fall?
Oh.
We're fine.
Oh wait, this is the same thing though.
Okay, hold on.
Get me out of here.
I'm trapped.
I'm trapped for real.
Okay, good.
I didn't want it beeping at me anymore.
Spooky old tree equals peak childhood breathing.
She restored the timeline.
Oh, Fruit of the Loom has the cornucopia again.
Oh, man.
Jumped in and I'm lagging hard.
Did I come in at a weird time?
I don't think so.
Is it me?
Is it really lagging sometimes?
It must be me.
Okay, hold on.
I'm figuring this out.
Actually, I think we could just do this.
Oh, so close.
Wait.
The tree is just barely getting away.
That should be it.
But then we have to do it again, huh?
There we go.
Something's happened in a while.
Okay, good, good.
Sorry about that.
Hopefully I get better internet soon.
Finkies crossed, special Jiu-Jiu-Jiu and Liu Ying-Chang's
collection copies inside, stack last.
Okay.
Are those new characters, new people?
I'm meant to be thinking out loud here, archiving my
thoughts.
No lagging in you, let's go!
We mess with water.
All the time in our workspaces.
We can't follow ourselves so much longer.
The time that runs out, you won't get back.
Oh.
Oh, no.
I have to be mega quick.
What?
Oh, there we go.
Your speed is impressive.
Oh, my thank you.
Pet the kitty, pet the kitty.
Stonehenge.
I'm suddenly It's combat Playing in my head Wait, can we go?
Let me in, let me in
This is so Fascinating Isn't it?
I've always wondered about your world inside I must know
Does it still look like this?
Cutie patootie It does It does look like It's as...
It's as...
Anticlimactic as you see it now.
Whoa!
Exploration pays, baby.
Wait.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Caitlyn.
Caitlyn, can you assist?
Caitlyn, we need assistance.
Caitlyn?
Rearun!
Oh, wow.
Welcome to Mambusha, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Or is that a welcome back?
Welcome back!
Thank you!
Kaelin!
No escape from the hinge.
Hoi!
Oh, Kaelin!
Kaelin, we actually gotta go back.
Wait, do I get to keep the Majong thing that I got?
Reminder that the work you're doing here will save humanity
from itself.
where okay there's a lot going on here let's figure it out
would you over here where'd you go you're who's who's what
what what
does this machine you're looking for really provide all the
answers oh the weather machine i wish that for all our
troubles nailed it one simple solution Don't worry, it's
gone.
Well, it's worth a shot.
I thought that would sound happy, but it just sends.
Never mind.
Why are you so nihilistic for a computer cat?
Ooh.
Jordan, welcome back.
Thank you.
Oh.
What the heck?
I feel like I'm in Ripley's, believe it or not.
Sometimes.
Wait, I don't have my camera!
Is this a...
Whoa!
What the heck?
Is this a level or was this a challenge?
Am I crazy?
Wait, did I go to a level or did I go... Wait, hold on.
Exit level?
Let me double...
Oh no, yeah, teleport to next level.
Oh.
wait there we go okay let's
go this way first i definitely think i need my camera it's
five step plan for saving mirin's project step one trash bad
schematics out of sight out of mind two repurpose bio
filtration data for mirin's original architect idea
architecture idea step three invite mirin over for mahjong
step four commence inevitable fight over mahjong step Step
4, make her see reason.
Step 4, talk about how much fun we had building the
teleporter.
Step 5, reminder that failure is part of the journey to
success.
Step 5, hit the road and get out of Dodge.
Step 5, brainstorm new good schematics.
It's fake.
It's all fake.
Okay.
Okay, it's still real.
It's still real.
It's fake.
What am I supposed to do without my camera?
What am I supposed to do?
Ugh.
It's tripping me up.
I'm actually in the Looney Tunes.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Roadrunner cartoons?
Perception, yeah, but is it gonna, like, appear, you know?
I have to go back in here.
No.
Quantum particles are only real when they're observed, so
you're telling me I don't need to look at it.
Got it.
So if I look, if I don't look, I'll go back.
Wait a second.
Whoa!
Don't do it again.
Okay then I'm scared.
I need you here.
Roll runner cartoons.
Your honor, she's cooking.
Jury and members of the audience.
I present to you.
Your dinner.
Be our guest, to be our guest to the test.
And next wrap your napkin round your neck shall we and we'll
provide the rest some those bamboo and champagne and the
dinner is oh was
it always like that I'm so it's a bit clever isn't it well
we will be going course by course oh one by one oh till you
shout oh and up find on and then you are going to pet the
cat and then we move out of the Be a guest!
I thought we came together to compare notes.
I don't have anything new to share.
Are you sure?
There's always something new to explore here.
Nothing of value yet, but soon.
That was a nice idea, Aron.
Relaxing even.
Thank you.
Where?
Don't you think it's time we got back to work?
This is a disaster.
I need to speak of Miram before this gets any worse.
Where has she been anyway?
She's so busy with her work, I haven't seen her outside her
space in a while.
I'll give her a call.
This can't go on.
What's happening?
Everything's falling apart.
I think last is Mirren's world, right?
So, I like that you can sit in like any chair and just kind
of vibe.
Oh, who's that in the chair across from me?
Wow, he's got such sick moves.
Funny looking stairs.
Wow!
This game!
Whoa!
These ones I could tell though.
I guess from far away, but these ones you can tell they go
out with their stairs.
That's cool too.
Bird?
Whoa!
Yeah, you have to Indiana Jones it!
Oh!
Filtration system proofs for...
Al-Lung.
Disassemblage number 226.
Who was it who said insanity is doing the same thing over
and over and expecting different results?
Wait, what does this mean?
Just...
Maybe it's these?
It's the path we take.
So...
Wait, I can't...
Wait, I wish I could take a picture of it.
Because I need to flip it upside down, no?
We do a figure eight, but it's gonna be...
This one, I think.
Right?
Loop around the top left.
Oh, nice.
Wait.
Did that even...
Was that always there?
No.
That appeared.
Yes!
First try!
Oh, just one battery.
I guess that makes sense since we don't have the camera
anymore.
Storage locker.
This game That was not there before It was an actual battery
before It was an actual battery before It was It was an
actual Battery before Can
I turn it?
Sure, sure
Is this battery in the room with us?
Well, clearly not.
Wait a second.
I think I can still use this, though, no?
Check it.
Oh, wait.
I messed up.
Sorry.
There we go.
Wait.
Oh, I was going to, like, get another picture of it.
You think I should restart?
No, it doesn't work.
Yeah.
I think you have to.
Watch.
It's a little closer.
Woo.
Take a photo while it's real.
Oh, good idea.
Let's try it.
Yeah, that's a much better idea yeah yeah oh well we got it
good thinking good thinking
oh you I can't
way this one is cheeky it will work it will
I'm like wondering, do I have to do something really dumb?
Like, I don't
know.
Do I need to take another picture?
I get to see a Minky on my birthday!
Oh, Team Red!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Is it still gonna be funny?
It is.
Hinto is the type of girl who would slam her face on a
painting of a tunnel trying to chase the roadrunner.
Okay, well...
There was one time it was my friend's birthday party.
And they were all outside eating cake.
And they had a glass door.
And I went to the bathroom and everyone went outside.
And when I came out of the bathroom, they were like...
They were like, come on, Mito!
Come on, we're gonna get cake!
And I was like, here I come!
And like, I like a cartoon character, I revved my legs up.
And bang!
It was a very clean, very clean glass door.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, I'm going to have a new
Guys, I'm stumped with this one I'm stumped I'm stumped I'm
stumped
When I was like 10 Literally the first night in our new
house I ran straight through the screen door Because I
didn't see it No way Okay Can you try zooming in with the
camera through the hole?
Unfortunately, it does not work that way.
Oh, the cartoon character that you are.
Oh, oopsie.
Yeah, there's no zooming.
My dad did that for dinner when he was a kid, but apparently
hard enough that he shattered the glass.
Let gravity do it.
What if I, like, let it fall?
What a crazy solution!
No way!
Don't you find it fascinating?
The solutions our minds can cultivate when given the space
and motivation.
They might not always be perfect, but they are special.
They are special.
Let's see.
I think that's the completion of this.
machine you're looking for yeah it's not the only chance you
have the only solution your mind is decided upon why is he
like then there's only forward isn't there why is he why is
he making us why is he like making us doubt that this is a
good thing mega mind maxing for real let's go my sister had
a similar incident but less funny glass broke so she had to
get stitches oh I'm glad my friends, they got quality glass,
or maybe I'm just, I am a ghost, so how much damage can I
do, right?
My siblings and I didn't have enough times at an old cottage
of ours that our parents put up those bird-spooking stickers
on it to remind us it was there.
Oh, I used to not feel alone in that.
I went into a glass door with a plate of jello.
The proof was everywhere.
Yeah, ectoplasm squeesh.
Oh, wait, we have two more levels.
Mirren and then something else.
Who else have we seen?
We've talked...
We've seen...
I guess some other people have been mentioned.
But, I think...
We'll call it here.
I'll probably return to this just sometime whenever I feel
like braining again.
but
I like the puzzles in this so far most of them only that
last one I feel like is the one that stumped me the most
mostly doing alright I feel with some of these although like
I'll like look at it for an extra second or something but
why are we so small Yeah, chill fun puzzles.
Yeah.
One time I walked into a glass door, I saw an image of
someone I didn't know that person was by a reflection.
And then I hit my face into the door.
What are you like a dog barking at your reflection?
I've been drawing with you in the background.
Oh, thank you.
I hope you've been drawing good stuff.
Yeah, some of them were pretty clever, weren't they?
Yeah, they were pretty fun.
Thank you, Big Brain, Minto, for the stream.
I hope you, and every Ibu have a wonderful weekend.
Me too.
I hope you guys all have a great weekend putting on my
smarty pants glasses here.
Since today we were all smarty pants.
Good job, guys.
I'm so excited for my new outfit on Monday.
I'm so excited.
I don't know what else to say about it.
There's like technically one last thing I'm waiting on, but
it's not a big deal if it doesn't come in time.
If it's not delivered in time.
Everything else is just...
Uh, me.
Everything else is just me, so.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
When is the reveal Monday?
Monday, Monday, Monday.
The 20th.
The...
20th?
Uh...
The 20th!
Very exciting.
The 20th?
4 p.m.
PST.
7 p.m.
EST.
And that's all I can remember.
My restaurant rush is about to happen.
I'll survive.
You got this!
You will survive!
You will survive.
Also, I wonder if maybe people have DVR on because I
accidentally had it on when I first started the stream so if
your internet was being stinky maybe the stream was
stuttering maybe it was that 8 a.m.
JST but that is the 21st 8 a.m.
thanks for the mind-bending stream and great dog coming up
with a big brain solution sorry go thank you so much for the
peeing hope you have an awesome night enjoy your spaghetti
ramen or whatever your dinner of choice happens to be thank
you what should I get what do you guys think I did have
spaghetti yesterday I could have leftovers again or I can
have ramen mmm I don't
know not Taco Bell no get some
ramen pizza the best pizza in all of London I did say you
were craving ramen I just haven't had it in a while I had
this one place that i loved and they had a limited time menu
and them they had a uh or rather they had like they did have
a limited menu and like or run one ramen that would be
limited for a season and one season they had it was like my
it was it was created specifically for me i think it was a
it was a Chiyo Raman with garlic,
broccoli, tomato, and corn.
And after it, I was like, oh my gosh, this, I went several
times that season.
I was like, this is, this is the bestest ever.
This is the best ever.
year i hope they bring it back next year so i can have it
again and you know what happened the year after they shut
down i should see if they're in my new town i don't know but
it's a it's a true tragedy isn't it it's such a tragedy i'm
so It's actually like, I think about that.
I have a picture of it, like that I, that I, like a picture
of the menu that I saved of it.
That I'm like, oh, one day.
One day I'll see you again.
Maybe.
One day.
Let's see.
No, none in my area.
They do have some, hmm.
No, I don't know.
It's kind of far.
Oh, man.
Just trying to cope.
Starcrest lovers, yeah.
Those mahjong tiles are starting to look really yummy.
They kind of look like jelly.
Like a haichu.
They look like a haichu.
My lunch was a boargoor.
I specified no lettuce.
They added lettuce!
I ate it, but it was a yummy boargo.
Dargo!
You can't!
They look like haichu.
that was nice though i give no rip you in two weeks oh
i'll see if there's any good ramen around me i'd eat some
jelly majean tiles me too be like reechy have you seen
jimothy the seattle raccoon
seeing an animal besides a dog with the shortened spine
syndrome i can't remember what he's called he's so cute i
keep getting videos of him jibiti apparently if you haven't
seen him he is a raccoon with a shortened spine if you've
seen like dogs that are like they're like they're all
they're super super squished and and and yeah you have to
look him up he's such a stink he looks like a cryptid like
he's so cute he's so cute oh my goodness jimothy yeah but
i've i read about the shortened spine is that apparently it
does not hurt the animals but maybe they have some joint
pains growing up but it's such a cryptid he's so cute i feel
like maybe he is what like the chupacabra was or something
like but a dog you know yeah i hope i hope i hope people
don't be mean to him because he's like kind of going viral
right now i hope people leave him alone and let him live his
little shortened and yeah what about the blood drinking
though that was me I don't know it came from beyond the
borderline it's the night I will
go full John Wick if anyone touches him yeah me too I'll
march my butt to Seattle and I'll say My name is Minta
Fenton You killed my Scrunkel raccoon Prepare to die That's
what I would say Stream night of the Chupacabra Yay I love
that song while jogging Thank you Thank you for listening to
it Thank you That's a Toho Eurobeat song I did A
collaboration with A1 If you want to possess anyone, I just
ordered cord ramen on seamless!
Topki!
I'm coming over!
Minta Montoya.
I still remember you looping it during Horizon.
I should play Horizon again, Forza.
Yeah.
I haven't played since.
I haven't had time though.
Gosh.
No time recently to play games.
Relaxing.
Later the Chupacabra available on streaming services and
physical media for those who look for it.
It is!
You can!
Actually if you order it physically, you can get a magnet
with it.
Yes, yes, yes.
You've been very busy.
Yeah.
But that's okay.
That's why I like playing games on stream anyway.
So it works out, but it is nice to sometimes play a game
that I want to play, but don't have, don't want to
necessarily want to stream.
I think for those, though, I might just do them as members.
Less pressure.
So I can just play whatever I want, but as a member, so.
I'm heading to my first rock concert on Wednesday.
Whoa!
Have fun!
Glad you aren't getting burnt out.
No, I'm okay.
I do have a lot of work before off-cut i'll i'll say that i
do have a lot of work but it's fun stuff it's good stuff
lots of stuff happening yeah yeah well maybe i will go eat
dinner now all the food talk made me hungry and after
off-cut and after that i actually i think things truly like
less plans truly and starting of September.
Less like huge, big stuff, you know?
So...
Yeah, so after September, I think we'll have some rest a
little bit.
Phoebe's still streaming!
Great!
We will raid into Phoebe Chan Chibi.
It's her six month anniversary.
Please give her all the love.
Six...
I keep saying month!
Six year anniversary!
Six year anniversary I can't wait to see you I can't wait to
hang out I'm gonna hang out with InSitu And we're gonna
perform together That's so crazy I'm so excited It's also so
funny that I keep seeing so many people's Six year
anniversaries around this time And I'm like wow Wow Wow So
many people joined, joined the VTubing in like 2020, but
it's, it's, it's everybody's time now.
And there's so many people that have come and gone and, uh,
everything is so different now.
But I hope that everybody, I hope you guys at least, you
know, everybody, you guys, everybody's still having fun.
I just like streaming.
I like streaming it is pretty far, so.
The people who were around for the 2020 are boomers.
The 2020 boom are the elders now.
I don't know.
I still feel...
I don't feel like a...
I don't know.
I feel very like...
I still don't know what I'm doing all the time.
Oh, I kind of...
Okay, since you guys stayed around to the very end, I did
want to give a little hint of something.
Not for a little bit while now.
You might have seen that Phoebe and Vicky got you two's
plushies.
But no Minto plushie.
How curious.
Well, maybe in some time.
Not you two's.
Maybe Minto plushie.
A new Minto plushie.
Sometime.
But this is a very...
in advance hint so don't expect it anytime soon but that's
all I'll say is that there is there is in the works there is
in the works so
minto plush tomorrow no no minke leaks I'll take your entire
stock of that minto plushie I would really appreciate that
because well i guess i shouldn't say anymore probably any
more than that would be a little too more plushie the fumo
baby is too energetic and needs someone to play with what
about what about tiny mean kinky anyways guys oh it's umito
but again please go give a phoebe lots and lots of love
marco thank you so much for the five gift day What?
Why are you making that face at me?
Oh my god.
Will they be eatable asking for a friend?
Maybe, probably.
Eat it.
Have a good day, have a good day, have a good time zone.
Bye bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
Don't be.
The YouTube emo is so, that's so goofy.
Wait, can I make my own?
Wait, what's my angry, angry one?
right now.
It's like this one.
What if I replace this one for... for the...
It makes me...
Okay.
I like it.
I look into doing that.
It's so funny.
Otomito!